But back to MO Theory,
which is where what we
talked about last Friday.
And there are sort
of two last things
I wanted to mention now
related to MO Theory
before moving on to the
topic of hybridization.
Now, before I do that, you
know, I'm going to use a couple
of videos today and I'm--
I'm not going to
show you this one,
but I just want
to mention there's
lots of videos that
help, you know,
animate this stuff, right?
So like this is what-- so like--
Oh, OK.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
Bonding molecular orbital.
[END PLAYBACK]
Antibonding, we talked
about this last Friday.
But look at this animation.
I couldn't do that on the board.
Watch this.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
Antibonding molecular
orbital formed
by the combination
of two 1s orbitals
are called sigma 1s and
sigma star 1s respectively.
[END PLAYBACK]
Kind of remembering stuff
now, right, from Friday?
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
The bonding molecular--
Oh, look at that.
-- is lower in energy than
the original [INAUDIBLE]..
[END PLAYBACK]
That's that kind of animation
that you just can't-- you know,
I can't animate the
bonding and antibonding.
Well, I kind of can with
my hands, but there it is.
And there's lots and lots
of those kinds of videos.
I'll show you a couple today
related to hybridization,
because it really
does help see these 3D
orbitals, right, in their full
shape and what's happening.
So I highly recommend
it, especially if you're
having some conceptual
questions related to stuff
we talked about
Friday and today.
Take a look at some
of those videos.
Now, where we left
off on Friday,
before I get to nitrous
nitric oxide, which
has all those different uses
in the world, and many more.
We left off with the
homonuclear dimers.
That's what we were
doing on Friday, right?
How do the atomic
orbitals come together
to make orbitals that
are molecular MOs, right?
And we did it for dimers that
have the same atom, right?
And so here-- so we did nitrogen
and 2 and we did O2, right?
And so let's do
that on the board
and that-- because
now we're going
to start with one that has N and
O, heteronuclear dimer, right?
Two different atoms.
But if I had the
same one, remember,
this is what it would
look like, right?
So here-- here
would be, say, N2.
Would-- you know, I'm going to
just stick with the valence.
So the 2s for our nitrogen
atom, and the 2p would have,
remember, Hund's rule.
All right.
OK.
So that's what the
2p would look like.
And then over here, we
would have the other atom.
This is how we roll
when we talk about MOs.
And we'd have the 2s over here.
And this is how we start.
These are my AOs for
the 2 nitrogen atoms.
Right.
This is what we did, we're
just getting back in the mood
because we had the long weekend.
And when we make
the MOs, remember,
we have all those sort
of things that we talked
about in terms of how these--
this difference between the
bonding and the antibonding
orbital, right, is
related to the overlap
in the same symmetry of the
two AOs that come together.
[INAUDIBLE] we
talked about that,
the more overlap, the
biggest this delta.
Gesundheit.
All right.
And then we also-- so
that would be filled,
this would be filled, right?
Sigma 2 s, sigma a.
Sigma star 2s, right?
And then for nitrogen, we
also talked about how--
oh, boy, these are
reversed, right?
See, I'm now
already...
...backwards twice,
which is not what I want.
OK.
And this was-- but this is the
weird thing about nitrogen,
because if we go to oxygen, then
the way it goes is, you know,
you've got your
2s in oxygen. OK.
And in oxygen, you've got your
6 valence electrons in the 2p.
And over here, you've
also got the same.
OK.
And you've also got that 2s.
And-- but for oxygen--
OK.
So those are the
sigma, sigma star.
But for oxygen, we go to the
ordering that we usually have,
which is that-- remember,
those pi orbitals have--
and this isn't
necessarily on a scale.
But those pi
orbitals-- all right.
So this was sigma, sigma star,
and these are the pi orbitals.
Pi and pi star, right?
Sigma p.
All right.
2p, 2s, sigma.
This would be sigma s, sigma
2s, sigma 2s star, sigma 2p,
if you want to be
exact about it.
Sigma 2p star.
Pi x, pi y, pi x
star, pi y start.
We talked about
all this on Friday,
I'm just getting us
back in the mood.
But the way we left off
was that these are--
OK.
So for-- if I fill
these all up now--
right.
Remember, we do the
MO filling, then we'd
have this, and this, and--
ooh.
Now, hold on.
Yep.
This and there and there
for oxygen. And then
over here we're filling them up.
We got-- those are
filled, those are filled,
and this is filled for
nitrogen. Remember,
I showed the movie
pouring liquid oxygen,
pouring liquid nitrogen.
Oxygen has unpaired electrons,
which means it's paramagnetic.
It has unpaired.
Electrons, the O2 dimer.
This is O2.
These are the MOs of O2.
These are the atoms.
These are the MOs of N2.
N2 doesn't have any
unpaired electrons
so it's not paramagnetic.
But the thing that we left off
on-- that's what I'm saying
is, that these two switch
order for those dimers,
for lithium through
nitrogen. Those two switch.
All right.
We talked about that on Friday.
The reason is because for
those atoms, these sigma--
these sigma p orbitals can mix
in with the sigma s orbitals.
And so you get more.
Because, remember,
the more overlap,
the greater the energy, rate?
The greater that delta between
bonding and antibonding, right?
So the more mixing you have,
the more spread you get.
And it's so much that for those
dimers you push the orbital up.
OK.
That's all what we
talked about Friday.
Now, I got on of each.
I got one of these on the
board so that you can see them
as we now take one atom from
one side and one from the other.
It's actually kind
of what you expect.
You just have to have
one thing in mind
when you think about No--
so if this is N, OK,
over here, and we're
going to put 2s
there and 2p there.
Here, here, here, here.
There's my N atom.
And now I've got O over here.
So I've got my--
but, now, see, the thing is
always more electronegative.
And the way this works for
a heteronuclear dimer is--
let's write this on the board.
So for a heteronuclear, that
means that the two atoms
are different.
OK.
But for a heteronuclear
dimer, the bonding MOs
are closer in energy to the
more electronegative atom.
Electroneg atom.
Atom.
So what that means
is that if I draw--
so if I draw my oxygen levels--
but you know this, right?
You know this, also,
from all the work
we did on atoms, right?
You know a little
something about-- remember,
this axis is energy.
This axis is energy.
And so if this is 2s for
oxygen, and then the 2p's are
going to be sort of like here.
OK.
And we'll fill them up
thinking about Hund's rule.
Well, now, what we're going
to have is that those--
the MOs for the No molecule
are going to come closer,
they're going to come further
down from that side, right?
Then they come from that side.
Do you see that?
There's an asymmetry.
I made it kind of subtle.
I made it kind-- and
why is this curved?
That's not good.
What's going on here?
There's a little bit of
an asymmetry here, right?
So-- so this is lower down--
these are lower down, right?
So when you draw
your orbitals now--
oh, man.
I'm going to draw this
a little bit lower.
Right.
So now when you draw then,
you see that bonding orbital
is going to be closer.
You see, this is a
bonding orbital still.
It's still bonding, right?
It's going to be a
sigma p, sigma 2p.
But it's closer in energy to
the more electronegative levels.
You see that?
Right.
So it's not symmetric anymore.
OK.
And then the same what happened
with these guys, right,
they'd be closer
in energy to the--
yeah.
They would be closer.
And I'm not leaving
myself enough room here.
That's why I've got some videos.
They do it better.
All right.
OK.
We'll leave that one there.
It's a little bit better.
Not much, but a little bit.
So the bite-- now-- oh,
by the way, for No--
let's talk about MO for
a second, because there's
another thing that's
important that we talk about,
which is bond order,
and, you know, the bond--
oh, electron configuration
is another thing, right?
So like the configuration,
we can write this out, right?
So the configuration of, say,
02 would be sigma 2s, right,
you're just filling them
up with two electrons.
Sigma star 2s with
two electrons.
Sigma 2p with two electrons.
Pi, 2p with four
electrons, and then pi 2p
star with two electrons.
That's how that looks.
It's a little bit messy,
but I hope you can read it.
That's just reading up, right.
It's the electron
configuration of the MOs,
just like we would write
the s, p, d electron
configuration of that,
but this is a molecule.
Now, sometimes you
might, you know--
say there's a
convention we use, which
is that the pz is the sigma.
Nobody can agree on it,
so different textbooks say
px but we're saying
p-- if pz is sigma,
then this would be like a sigma
2pz, right, and you might,
if you really want
to write this,
you know, you might write that
that's pi 2px if you really
want to keep track of it.
There's 2 orbitals in there.
You didn't fill 1 orbital
with 4 electrons, right?
So this would be pi 2px
and pi 2py 4, right?
That's what's
happening in there.
OK.
But the other thing you
can see from the bot--
from this filling is,
also, the bond order.
And so for the bond order--
bond order, here you
would have 1/2 times,
and it's all of the--
remember, the bonder is all
of the bonding electrons
minus antibonding electrons
divided by 2, right.
And if it's zero, it's
not a stable molecule.
If it's greater than
zero, it's stable.
And the higher the bond order,
the higher the bond strength.
So that's also from Friday.
And so this is 2 minus 2 plus
4 minus 2, and so you get 2.
Nope.
I missed a 2.
Plus 2, plus 4 minus 2.
2 minus 2, that kind
of cancels out, right,
plus 2, plus 4, minus
2, all divided by 2.
So the bonder for oxy--
now, the bonder for No--
bond order for No
is going to be 2.5.
Well, that's kind of
interesting, now, you can see--
OK.
So No is stronger--
more strongly bound than O2,
less strongly bound than N2.
And it's kind of interesting.
How can I make No a stronger--
a more strongly bound molecule?
Well, I can take
an electron away.
It's a little bit
counterintuitive, right?
Because for No
plus, the bond order
goes up because the
electron that I'd taken away
was in an antibonding orbital.
Right.
So No plus actually has
a stronger bond than No,
even though it has
one less electron.
You get this all from just
looking at which electrons
are occupying which orbitals.
In this case, you had in this
very much not drawn to scale--
oh, boy-- figure, right.
What you had was one up there.
So if I take that out,
my bond order increases.
Right.
OK.
All right.
And the last point I wanted
to make about MO theory
before we talk
about hybridization
is with one other
example, and that's HTL.
OK.
So for HTL, you
got something else
happening that's important.
So we just talked
about electronegativity
driving where the-- you
know, that this is tilted.
OK.
Fine.
And now we got the
fact that chlorine
comes into this situation.
You know, it's like chlorine is
like, hey, I got 7 electrons.
And hydrogen is
like, hey, I got 1.
So how's this work, right.
So this gets to what was
brought up Friday, which
is, there's another type of MO.
And it's not bonding,
and it's not antibonding,
it's non-bonding.
That is not the
same as antibonding.
Non-bonding doesn't
take sides, it just is.
Because the way this works
is hydrogen comes at this--
OK.
So hydrogen's up
here with this 1s.
Chlorine is, you know,
let's say over here.
It's got 3s filled,
and it's got--
let's draw these here.
OK.
3p.
And chlorine's got 7
electrons in the 3p.
Do they-- do they all come
together and form MOs?
No, they can't, because there's
only 1 on this side, right.
So this 1 orbital will form--
let me make myself
enough space so I'm
going to exaggerate
this a little bit.
So this 1 orbital will
form a sigma bond.
Sigma 3p, sigma 3p bond.
This would be a sigma 3p star.
Now, that's exactly what we've
already done, right, the sigma.
But-- but-- oh, there's
something a little interesting
about this one, right,
because it's an s.
It's an s.
But that's OK because the
s can talk to a sigma p.
This is -- we talked about this.
The s can talk to this.
That's OK.
Because it's aligned, right.
Now, but these guys don't
have anyone to talk to.
They don't.
So they can't make
their pi orbitals.
They can't do that.
And so they just stay there.
These stay there exactly
at the same place.
They're not doing
anything different.
They're just hanging out.
Those electrons are non-bonding.
So these are not pi orbitals.
Sigma and pi are special names.
They refer to these orbitals
of the molecule that
involve the LCAO, the
linear combination
of the atomic orbitals.
These do not.
Nb.
That's what we'll call them.
Just to be very clear.
Now, they're filled.
They're filled, and they do
not count in the bond order.
By the way, this is, also,
a non-bonding orbital.
That's a non-bonding orbital.
Non-bonding orbitals.
These are not going to count.
So in the bond order,
you only have--
you have 1/2 times 2
minus 0 equals one.
These do not
participate in bonding.
I got to fill this.
2 electrons are in that one.
OK.
So that's another
example of something
that happens in
these MO diagrams.
One of them brought too
many electrons to the party.
And so there's no
one to talk to.
But it's OK.
They're just going to
stay there and wait.
Maybe something else
will come along.
Right.
OK.
Now, that is, right there,
what I just drew, look at that.
2p 2s, and you get
this thing, right.
Oh, it's a beautiful
molecular orbital between--
OK.
Fine.
It was a 1s and a 3p,
but you get the point.
It was a p oriented along
the axis with sigma symmetry.
That means if I look
along the axis-- sorry,
cylindrical
symmetry, sigma means
if I look around the
axis, everything is
the same, in a circle, right?
Right.
So-- but-- and so that's
a nice sigma orbital
between two different atoms.
MO theory.
But see the other thing that
can happen that is something
that I want you
to know today, is
that orbitals on the exact
same atom can also do this.
They can also do this.
They can combine to
form a new orbital.
sp, same atom forms
an sp orbital.
It's called a hybrid orbital.
So we're going to give
a couple of examples.
This is hybridization.
Hybridization.
And I can give a
couple of examples,
then my [INAUDIBLE] matters.
So this is when two or more
ao's that are similar in energy.
They're similar, they're not
the same but they're close.
You know, you can't
hybridize if one level's
way up here and the other
level's way down there.
But if they're close, 2s
2p, then those orbitals
can combine.
And what they do is
they combine to form,
and this is critical, sets of
equivalent orbitals properly
oriented.
This is really important.
That's why I'm
writing it all out.
Properly, not property.
Properly oriented to form bonds.
Oh, this is such a big
deal, to form bonds.
It's the last word there, but
I did it all caps to emphasize.
Because that's what
this is all about.
You see, it-- now,
let's take an example.
I'm going to take an
example of methane.
Who brings what to the party?
OK.
I got H--
I've got 4 H's.
H1s, H1s, H1s, OK.
This is definitely
getting repetitive.
H1s.
But I did it.
There they are.
And they come, and they're
like, hey, carbon, what you got?
And the carbon is
like, OK, hold up.
I got my 2s, that's
here, and I got my--
all my 2p's, and
what are we to do?
What are we to do?
How can these four
hydrogens come
and bond with the carbon
given that it looks,
at least, like the carbon isn't
bringing the kind-- you know,
how's it going to do this?
And, also-- and
this is critical.
This is why I wrote it here.
Properly oriented to form bonds.
You see, because this
taps into what we
learned with VSEPR It
does, because VSEPR
says you got to not repel.
Or, no, you're repelling,
but try to minimize it.
I mean, that's what's
at the core of VSEPR.
So what this system
sees is a way out.
And by way out, I mean
a way to happiness.
And by a way to
happiness, I mean a way
to lower energy where all 4 of
these can bond to the carbon
atom if it has 4 same bonds.
If it had 4 same bonds, then it
can orient them tetrahedrally
and make VSEPR happy,
minimize repulsions, right.
And you get your
methane molecule.
So what ends up happening
is this carbon atoms says,
hold up.
You 4 hydrogens,
you wait there, I'm
just going to go into the back
and do a little reorganization,
and I'm going to
come in it with--
I'm going to say,
well, if I had--
if my carbon atom comes at--
comes at it with 4 equal
orbitals that look like this,
those are called sp3, because
I took all 3 p orbitals
and I mix them up
with my s orbital
and I formed
equivalent orbitals.
Now, carbon comes out of the
back room, and it's like,
hydrogens, I'm ready, I
can make a minimum energy,
and I can follow
VSEPR and we can
have-- all have very,
very low energy, compared
to whatever else I could've
done, if I stuck like that.
What I'm really talking
about when I'm talk--
OK.
You might know
carbon, you know, it
doesn't go into the back room.
It doesn't.
But what is it doing?
It's nothing more than solving
its Schrodinger equation.
That's what this is all about.
You just change the
boundary conditions.
And so what happened--
that's all hybridization is.
You're solving the Schrodinger
equation all the time.
We are always solving
the Schrodinger equation
all the time.
And in this case,
carbon said, well,
how can I solve it and minimize
my energy with the 4 hydrogens?
This gives you
the lowest energy.
Because, now--
oh, I got a movie.
Now, I can make those, see.
So I have them--
I have a picture here.
s and those three.
And it says, how can I do
it and minimize repulsions?
This is how.
Three equivalent-- 4 equivalent
orbitals to make it sp3.
And this is where I
think a movie helps.
So I'm going to play this.
It's like a minute long.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
Each 2s orbital is
a two lobe shape
converging at the nucleus.
- There's the 2s.
So there are the
three 2p orbitals.
However, when
hybridization occurs,
the s and p orbitals
cease to exist,
They don't cease to
exist, they just didn't--
it's a new boundary condition.
You're solving the equation.
Right.
So just to keep that
straight, right?
These are the orbitals--
and the two sp3 orbitals have
an entirely different shape.
- That's true.
We can see that orbital
hybridization explains
the VSEPR placement of
carbons for VLANs electrons.
Since all four 2sp3
orbitals are equivalent,
each 2sp3 orbital repels
the others with equal force,
resulting in
identical bond angles.
The carbon atom
only hybridizes when
it is in a bonding situation.
Here, four hydrogen
atoms bond to carbon
by overlapping their orbitals
with carbon's hybrid orbitals.
So what would be
the reason for this?
If we go back and see that
both carbon and hydrogen have
unpaired electrons,
the overlap allows
the electrons to pair, and thus
go to a lower potential energy.
[END PLAYBACK]
Oh, that's such a
beautiful place to stop.
Lower potential energy.
Happier.
That's what this is all about.
OK.
So I-- you know, like I said,
you can see now the difference,
right, if you just watch--
it's one minute long,
and I think it really
brings it to life.
So if you're, again, want
to see this a little bit
more conceptually,
these movies are good.
I have one more movie I'll show
you that's like a minute long.
OK.
Now, the thing is--
so what we just
did is we did carbon
hybridizes to sp3.
It's called sp3 because
you're bringing 3p orbitals
and mixing them
with s to form 4.
And that allowed it to do this.
But, you see, if I had
ethane, which is C2H6,
it's the same thing.
Now-- because, basically,
what's happening?
A carbon atom comes into this
system of ethane, and it says,
I need 4 bonds that are
kind of equivalent-ish.
All right.
I got to give one
to each hydrogen
and I've got to give one to
that other carbon over there.
And by doing that, it
can minimize its energy,
it can minimize repulsions, it
can be the happiest molecule
it can be.
But to do that, carbon must
have these four equivalent
sigma like bonds.
It must be able to form
those four equivalency.
So that's very similar to
methane, except that in this--
so, also, ethane will
be sp3 hybridized.
It will have sp3
hybridized orbitals.
But then, and you know
it's coming, right,
so ethane has C2H6.
But what if now
I've got ethylene.
I think I have-- maybe
I have a picture of it.
Do I have a picture of it?
Yeah.
Oh, there it is.
Ethylene.
Ethylene is used.
This tiny molecule is 2 carbons
and 4 hydrogen instead of 6.
This is used in so many
applications I can't possibly
list them.
If polyethylene is a polymer
made out of this as a base,
we will polymerize this a
little bit later in the semester
when we talk about polymers.
It's also used in the back
of your supermarket in case
you didn't know that.
Very soon-- actually,
kind of almost now-ish,
most of the fruit we get will be
super green when it gets here.
And then they use ethylene
to actually induce, sadly,
the brightness.
Doesn't taste as good.
But, anyway-- OK.
Now, but for ethylene, you've
got a different situation.
Because for ethylene, each
carbon atom needs 3 bonds.
Each carbon atom needs
3 equivalent bonds.
And it can do that, too.
So, for C2H4, each carbon
atom needs 3 equivalent bonds,
and it can do that
if it hybridizes
in the sp2 hybridization.
So let's draw that, right.
So these are the original
orbitals of carbon.
And they will go
to 3 sp2 orbitals.
Notice, I can put one electron
in each ready for action.
Ready for bonding.
One electron in each of these
equivalent hybrid orbitals,
sp2.
And I got one left over.
Ho, ho, oh.
One left over.
But the one left
over is a p orbital
that didn't get in
on the hybridization.
But that's OK.
That's OK.
These are p, right.
So this is s and this is p2s 2p.
And that's a p
orbital right there.
Those are my hybrids,
and that's a 2p orbital.
There's another 2p orbital
on the other carbon.
Also, got left out.
Now, I only needed
3 because, you
see, I formed this
nice spatially maximize
to minimize repulsion,
right, separation,
maximize to minimize
repulsion so it's a planar--
oh, but it's a planar
for another reason.
Because each of these carbon
atoms has a p orbital,
and we know that 2p orbitals
can form a pi bond, right?
And I have a picture of that.
That's exactly what they do.
So this is the sigma.
The hybrid orbitals
are sigma, right,
because they're along the
axis, and look at them.
If I look down this axis,
I can draw a circle,
and there's full
cylindrical symmetry, right.
But I've got this
left over p orbital
here on each carbon atom.
That's that one there.
And I didn't need it to do
this but it's still there.
And so it forms a bond.
It forms a bond.
Right.
It forms a pi bond.
So that p with the p
from the other one forms
a pi and a pi star,
right, in the MOs,
and you occupy the pi
with the two electrons.
And that's a bond.
So in this you've got--
you've got a bond from this
that's above or below--
in this orientation, it's
above or below the plane.
And you've got a bond from this.
So you've got a double bond.
That's exactly what
we know already,
but we know so much more now.
We know so much more.
Because-- because, now, we
know that it's not just two--
you know, two bonds
and four electrons,
we know that they
have shape to them.
We know that they have
structure to them,
and we know that those
bonds are different.
These are pi bonds, and
that's a sigma bond.
Right.
And you, also, know why
this molecule stays planar.
Because if I try to twist
it, then those p orbitals
won't align, right.
It's like a little spring.
If I-- if I try to twist it,
it's going to go right back.
Because it's minimum in
energy is when these things
can maximize their overlap.
All right.
So that's going to stay planar.
OK.
Now-- and so for this case,
you've got a double bond.
So this is double bond, and I
think I have a little carbon,
carbon, double bond.
And I think I've got
a video to show this,
because this is another
case where, you know,
again, I just want to
make sure you guys get
the intuition here,
and I thought this is
a pretty cool animation of sp2.
So I'll play it for a minute.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[INAUDIBLE] bonds.
The one 2s and two of the
2p orbitals hybridize.
Consequently--
- That's cool animation.
--this hybridization is
termed as sp2 hybridization.
- Look at that.
The hybridization leads to
the formation of 3 [INAUDIBLE]
sp2 hybrid orbitals.
As you can see, each sp2
hybrid orbital is bilobed.
One lobe bigger than the other.
The half-filled p
orbital, which was not
involved in hybridization,
flies at right angles
to the plane of the
equilateral triangle.
Now, let us understand
how this hybridized
state results in the
formation of a double bond.
For this, imagine a similar
sp2 hybridized carbon atom
approaching this carbon atom.
As these atoms come
closer, an orbital overlap
takes place along the
internuclear axes.
This bond is called
a sigma bond.
At this stage, the
unhybridized p orbitals
which lie above and below the
plane of the sigma bond, also
come very close to each
other and overlap laterally,
resulting in the formation of a
pi bond between the two carbon
atoms.
[END PLAYBACK]
All right.
OK.
So I thought about it.
I watched that movie, of course,
many times over the weekend.
And I thought about can
I animate, you know,
the electrons like that
and do the-- and I--
I think I could.
But I don't know that it would
be a good use of our time.
So I thought that they did a
pretty good job of bringing it
to life.
Now, this is a great
time for me to tell you
about my why this matters.
And, of course,
the sp2 carbon atom
matters because of
drinking water, of course.
And, you know, this is a well--
in a district in India where
more than 50% of the wells
exceed the WHO
limits for arsenic
by around a factor of 5.
1.8 billion people in the world
drink fecally contaminated
water on a daily basis.
600 million people boil
their water in the world.
Boiling doesn't help
with arsenic, though,
arsenic just stays
in the boiled water.
It kills bacteria, but it
doesn't help with toxic--
toxic elements.
If you look at the
world as a whole,
and you look at sort of
where there are water--
water crisis, where the water
crisis is at this level,
it's a little over 3
and 1/2 billion people.
And in those countries,
almost 185 or so countries,
where this is a
serious problem, if you
look at the cost of disease,
and the cause of death
in those countries, 70% to 80%
of all disease and almost 30%
of all death can be attributed
to the water quality.
Right.
So when I talk about
water as a problem,
I really mean it's
a serious problem.
It's a problem of life or death.
Now, this is-- to get
fresh drinking water,
if you look at the planet,
and you say, well, where
is the water on this planet?
Where is the water
on this planet?
I like this picture because we
consume water volumetrically,
not in an area, right?
We use water as a
volume, and this
is the water we have on this
precious planet as a volume.
This bubble here is
all of the ocean water.
It's about 70-- it's about
97% of all the water.
That bubble there is freshwater
that is inaccessible.
It's frozen.
And this one here, you
can't really see it,
there is another dot there.
That's less than 1%
of the world's water.
That is our drinking
water ecosystem
that is what we are destroying.
And-- so what--
OK.
So there's a lot of things
we can try to do about this.
One of the things
we can try to do
is to see if we
can tap into this
in a way that's more
affordable and more efficient.
Because there's a lot of water
here, right, and use that.
But the problem is, if you look
at the cost of desalination
today as opposed to the
cost-- that's desalination.
If you look at the
cost as opposed
to just digging
water out of a well,
like the one I just
showed you in India,
it's over a factor of 10.
Still.
And, in fact, one of the
big issues with desalination
isn't just the total cost
or the operating costs,
but the capital cost.
How do you build this
plant in the first place?
And so it takes too much money.
If you look at the thing that's
at the heart of desalination,
it's a filter, right.
It's a filter.
And I talked about
this in my last,
why this matters, when I
talk about separations,
and I promised that in my
next why does this matter,
I'd talk about water.
Right.
Which is what I'm doing.
If you look at a
desal plant, this
is one of the world's largest,
this is a plant called
the Hadera plant
in Israel, and you
look at what their costs
are that-- remember,
the costs digits-- half of that
cost-- almost half of the cost
isn't just energy.
And almost all of that energy
is in pushing salt water
through a filter.
Through a membrane.
That's called a reverse
osmosis membrane,
because you're going against
the osmotic pressure.
And if you look at
the membrane itself--
this is a picture
of it, it's actually
a very small layer on top
of this active layer that
does all the work--
it's not a very good design.
In fact, membranes for
desalination are pretty bad.
Right.
They kind of do everything
worse than they should,
except that they work, which
is good, and they're cheap,
$1.00 a square foot.
But, see, they're very--
they take much more energy
than you need.
They foul up very easily.
And then that means stuff
gets kind of, you know,
stuck in them.
And then you can't take
it-- you can't clean them
because these polyamide
membranes, which
are the same polymer used in
these membranes for 50 years,
haven't changed, the material.
Those polyamide membranes
are destroyed by chlorine.
So even in a desal
plant-- in a desal plant,
if you have drinking
water in your feed stream,
drinking water has six
parts per million chlorine.
That's not much.
They still will go through
the cost to remove it.
They will remove
it from the feed.
Why?
Because if you leave that little
amount of chlorine in the feed,
these membranes get destroyed.
By the way, there's 40,000 of
these membranes in this plant.
Each one is 2 meters long
and 40 square meters of area.
So-- so these are so delicate
that you can't really
clean them well.
And that's part of what the
cost of a plant involves.
That's part of what the
Now, this would be like
a plant, right, you
have sea water coming in
and, you know-- and then
you've got your membrane
module that's taking
the salt out of the water.
And then the product water.
But because this
filter is so delicate--
there's the picture--
because that filter
is so delicate,
you actually have to add a
whole lot more to the plant.
So much of a desal plant
is built around essentially
protecting this membrane.
So that's cost.
That's cost.
Right.
A better membrane
could change this.
But like I said, the
membrane-- oh, there it is.
You can't Snapchat on that.
Snapchat?
What is it that people do today?
Not Snapchat.
Yeah, Snapchat.
Yeah.
OK.
Thank you.
You can't Snapchat on that.
That's what I meant.
I know it's not My
Space, but I don't know--
but, anyway, this is like even--
you know, when I look at--
at membranes today as a
material scientist and materials
chemists, all of your
membranes, I think,
that's what it looks like.
Why?
Doesn't have to be the case.
We can do so much better.
And so-- OK.
Energy costs goes into
pretreatment, secondary
treatment, and this is
where this comes back.
This beautiful material that
we have now understood more
than we did before.
Because, remember,
before I showed
you graphene and I showed you--
no, I showed you benzene.
And we talked about it as
a Lewis resonant structure,
remember?
Right.
A Lewis resonant structure to
help explain how it looked.
You know, gra-- graphene does
not have alternating bonds.
Remember, that's what
we talked about before.
It's a Lewis resonant structure.
So it lowers its
energy by having
two sets of structures that
have sort of alternating bonds.
We talked about it in
the context of benzene.
But, see, now you
know so much more.
You know so much more.
Because, now, you know why
graphene is so special.
You know why graphene
is so special.
It actually is
the hybridization.
It's the hybridization.
Because on top,
and on the bottom,
of a single atom of a
single sheet of graphene,
you've got pi
bonding all the way.
Those pi bands are going
across the whole surface.
And those electrons
are critical.
Those electrons that
occupy those [INAUDIBLE]
are critical to the very special
properties that graphene has.
So you now know the secret.
It's sp2 hybridization.
And, you know, this
has allowed us--
this has-- you might
tell I'm kind of
passionate about this problem.
Partly impassioned passion
about a lot of problems
but, also, we happen
to work on this,
and we have been
developing this.
This is like the
ultimate membrane.
I can soak this in
chlorine overnight.
I can put it in
negative pH solutions.
I can heat it up.
It doesn't degrade.
And we have figured out
how to poke holes in it
at just the right
size, or to stitch it
together so that maybe you can
filter particles by the flow
in between these sheets.
Right.
And this material,
as a membrane,
is so promising
that we've actually
started to commercialize
it as of the last year.
And I think this is really
going to make a big difference
in a lot of areas.
Why?
Because of sp2 hybridization.
That is why.
That is why this is
such a special material.
OK.
That's my why this matters.
Now-- oh, we did see 2H6.
There it is.
We did see 2H4.
Look at that extra pi bond,
not animated this time.
And, of course, you can go
on and you could do see C2H2,
and you can imagine what
happens in this case,
is what you would expect.
Is what you would expect.
Because, now, I've only got--
see, each of these carbon atoms
only needs two sigma bonds.
One to the hydrogen and
one to the other carbon.
So it's only going to grab one--
it's only going to hybridize--
to make those two
equivalent signal bonds,
it's only going to hybridize
with one of the p electrons.
So that's sp.
That's sp hybridization.
But, notice, that in
C2H2, it-- you know,
now, I've got 2p orbitals
left over on each carbon atom.
And so you can imagine that
with these 2p orbitals,
well, you know this
already, right.
When-- when we talked
about p orbitals,
we talked about
how, you know, you
might-- you know,
you've got this, right.
Awe.
OK.
That's supposed to come
like out of the plane
and into the plane.
They're orthogonal.
Right.
And so-- so two of them are
coming at the other atom.
One is like this, and
the other's like that.
And then the other atom
is one like this and one--
well, it might not at first,
but then when it sees those,
it's like, hey, wait a second.
If I do this, we can pi bond.
Right.
The other ones are like
this, and they pi bond,
and so you get a carbon
carbon triple bond.
You get a carbon
carbon triple bond
for a C2H2 with
sp hybridization.
Now, it's not-- oh, there it is.
Right.
OK.
Forms pipe bond network,
forms sigma bond network.
It's not just carbon
that hybridizes.
It's not-- carbon is
a classic example.
But, you know, if you look
at BeH2, it's the same thing.
BeH2.
Well, Be, Be starts with an un--
can I raise this up?
Be starts with
orbitals that don't
look like they're going to give
me the equivalent two sigma
bonds.
Be starts with these
as electrons filled.
Right.
But if Be had something
more like this,
if it had an sp electron
in each of those orbitals,
well, now, when I see the two h
orbitals, the two 1 SH orbitals
coming at me, I can form
those equivalent bonds.
So BeH2 will also
hybridize [INAUDIBLE]
to make that molecule.
And all sorts of other things.
The deal orbitals can
get in on the action.
All right.
So here's SF6, which
we talked about.
We drew this Lewis structure.
Took a long time to
draw those lone pairs.
But, now, you know that
the way this actually
works because these
are equivalent bonds.
So the only way this can work
is if I form hybrid orbitals.
Right.
But they didn't have
to be equivalent bonds
until we learned about VSEPR.
And it said, no, I want
to maximize my separation
to minimize repulsions.
And so then we know that if
they're equivalent bonds,
the energy of the
system will be lower.
Right.
And so that-- that's--
you know, that's going to
have to take some d orbitals
and create these
hybrid orbitals.
Look, they're beautiful.
Because, now, this thing from
the sulfur, this thing can say,
hey, I can take six of you,
and I can be equivalent bonding
to all of you.
That's what hybridization is.
OK.
It's written right up there.
We're just keeping on
saying the same thing.
OK.
Now, I think that I'm sorry--
I got very excited
about the water
so I have to throw
some T-shirts out.
And, now, where do
I-- where do I--
OK.
I don't go there.
I got to go back
there, and back there.
Oh, that's very loud.
OK.
And right there.
See you guys on Friday.